Nous leur avons d'abord demandé leur intention de vote
entre les deux coalitions.
Puis nous leur avons demandé de répondre à 12 questions.
Après avoir rempli leurs réponses,
on leur demandait d'en discuter.
Pourquoi pensez-vous que les taxes sur l'essence devraient être augmentées ?
On passait toutes les questions en revue.
Puis on a constitué un modèle avec un code couleur
qui nous permettait de mesurer leur score final.
Donc cette personne avait un, deux, trois, quatre,
cinq, six, sept, huit, neuf points à gauche.
Bref, elle penchait plutôt à gauche.
Et à la fin, on demandait d'inscrire à nouveau l'intention de vote.
Mais bien sûr, il y avait aussi un truc.
D'abord, nous abordions les passants en leur demandant leur intention de vote.
Mais lorsqu'ils commençaient à remplir les questions,
nous remplissions une série de réponses à l'opposé des leurs.
Nous la mettions sous le bloc-notes.
Et quand nous recevions leur formulaire,
nous collions notre questionnaire au-dessus de celui-ci.
Voilà, disparu.
Nous leur demandions pour chaque question
quel était leur raisonnement.
Ils en expliquaient les raisons.
L'étape suivante, nous additionnions ensemble le score final.
En dernier lieu, ils énonçaient à nouveau leur intention de vote.
Ce que nous avons d'abord découvert,
c'est que très peu de personnes détectent ces manipulations.
Et si oui, pas dans le sens
où ils réalisent qu'on a manipulé leurs réponses.
Ils pensent plutôt :
« J'ai dû mal comprendre la question la première fois.
Est-ce que je peux la changer ? »
Et même si certaines de ces manipulations ont été corrigées,
la grande majorité est passée inaperçue.
Nous avons donc réussi à échanger 90% des réponses des participants
de la gauche à la droite, de la droite à la gauche, et changer leur profil général.
Que se passe-t-il lorsqu'on leur demande de motiver leurs choix ?
Ici, nous trouvons des résultats verbaux bien plus intéressants
que pour l'exercice des visages.
Les gens disent des choses comme ça, et je vais vous les lire :
« La surveillance gouvernementale des emails et du trafic Internet
doit être autorisée comme moyen de lutte contre le crime et le terrorisme.
Êtes-vous relativement d'accord avec ces propos ?
- Oui.
- Quel était votre raisonnement ?
- Eh bien, comme c'est difficile de s'attaquer au crime et au terrorisme,
je crois que ces outils devraient exister. »
Puis la personne se rappelle d'un article dans le journal du matin.
« Un article dans le journal ce matin
évoquait le fait qu'on peut écouter les conversations téléphoniques en prison,
si un chef de gang essaie de continuer ses activités de l'intérieur.
Je trouve hallucinant que l'on ait si peu de pouvoir
pour arrêter ces choses,
alors qu'on a la possibilité de le faire. »
Puis ils reviennent un peu sur leurs pas à la fin :
« Je n'aime pas qu'on ait accès à tout ce que je fais,
mais je crois que ça vaut le coup sur le long terme. »
Si vous ne saviez pas que cette personne
venait de participer à une expérience sur la cécité des choix,
vous ne remettriez probablement pas en question son attitude.
Que se passe-t-il à la fin, avec l'intention de vote ?
Nous avons découvert
que cela est aussi clairement influencé par le questionnaire.
Nous avons 10 participants
passant de gauche à droite ou de droite à gauche.
19 autres passent d'une intention de vote claire
à un vote incertain.
Certains passent d'un vote incertain à une intention de vote claire.
Quelques participants restent incertains tout au long de l'expérience.
Et ce nombre est intéressant
parce que si vous étudiez les résultats des sondages,
lorsque qu'une élection approche,
les seules personnes qui sont en jeu
sont celles qui sont considérées comme indécises.
Mais nous montrons ici qu'il y a un plus grand nombre
qui pourraient envisager de changer leur attitude.
Je dois mentionner qu'il est interdit d'utiliser cette expérience
comme méthode pour changer le vote des gens avant une élection.
Nous leur avons tout expliqué à la fin
et leur avons donné l'opportunité de revenir à leur premier choix.
Cette expérience prouve que si vous pouvez conduire les gens
à envisager une vision opposée à la leur et les encourager à un débat intérieur,
ils pourraient peut-être ainsi changer d'opinion.
Bien.
Qu'est-ce que tout ça signifie ?
Que se passe-t-il ?
Tout d'abord, ce que l'on appelle connaissance de soi
est souvent en fait une interprétation de soi.
Je me vois faire un choix,
et lorsqu'on me demande pourquoi,
j'essaie juste de le rendre le plus rationnel possible
lorsque je le justifie.
Mais c'est un processus si rapide et si facile
que nous pensons savoir la réponse lorsque nous rationalisons notre choix.
Comme c'est une interprétation,
nous faisons bien sûr des erreurs parfois.
Tout comme nous faisons des erreurs quand nous voulons comprendre les autres.
Faites attention lorsque vous demandez « pourquoi » aux gens,
car ce qui risque de se produire lorsque vous leur posez la question :
« Pourquoi êtes-vous en faveur de ce sujet ? »,
« Pourquoi restez-vous dans ce travail ou cette relation ? »,
ce qu'il risque de se passer à ce moment, c'est de créer une attitude
qui n'était pas là avant.
C'est tout aussi important dans votre vie professionnelle,
ou ça pourrait l'être.
Si vous créez quelque chose et que vous demandez :
« Pourquoi pensez-vous que c'est bon ou mauvais ? »
Ou, si vous êtes un journaliste et demandez à un politicien :
« Pourquoi avez-vous pris cette décision ? »
Ou encore, si vous êtes un politicien
et que vous voulez expliquer le pourquoi d'une certaine décision.
Tout ceci semble peut-être un peu perturbant.
Mais si vous voulez le considérer de façon positive,
ça pourrait signifier
que nous sommes en fait un peu plus flexibles que nous le pensons.
Nous pouvons changer d'avis.
Nos attitudes ne sont pas gravées dans le marbre.
Et nous pouvons aussi changer les avis des autres,
en les incitant à discuter d'un sujet
et à le considérer d'un point de vue opposé au leur.
Dans ma vie privée, depuis que j'ai commencé ces recherches,
ma compagne et moi partageons et respectons la règle
que l'on peut revenir sur quelque chose.
Parce que j'ai dit apprécier quelque chose l'an dernier
ne signifie pas que je l'apprécie toujours.
Se débarrasser du besoin de rester cohérent
est un vrai soulagement et rend nos relations bien plus faciles.
Dans tous les cas, voici la conclusion :
sachez que vous ne vous connaissez pas vous-mêmes.
Ou du moins, pas aussi bien que vous ne le pensez.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)